i was in indianapolis first of all what
an infinitely better city than oklahoma
city let me just say that right there i
don't know if our executive producer
ryan do you have any objections to that
is listening
[Laughter]
indianapolis what a far better city than
oklahoma city and why is that it was
just better so would you say the people
that come from that city are generally
better yeah actually no i'll give you
this i think oklahoma city has better
food but indianapolis was a better vibe
better vibe and that is undeniable i'll
take that yeah yeah you have to agree
because indianapolis does not have a
plethora of crack dens surround yeah now
you're leaving now you're leaving
the real highlight of the weekend was i
go into this bar across the street from
the venue because that's the that's the
one drawback to indianapolis there's
maybe like three things to eat after
nine o'clock steak and shake
they got these two bars and one of them
is called kilroy's and we go to kilroy's
and
music's playing and then out of nowhere
i start to hear a really familiar song
that's [ __ ] walkman what no way the
walkman starts playing and there's like
this table of moms they just start
turning the [ __ ] up and and by the way
by the way on this night it just so
happened that bieber was in town it's
all these moms in like bieber gear and
they're getting hyped and
i'm looking around i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on and so i think maybe
someone works there they're just being
funny and they think they saw you and
they turned it on yeah and then maybe
like like some like waiter might walk by
like i was just [ __ ] with you man
like whatever so i like kind of like
look around and i'm just seeing a bunch
of drunk people start like dancing to
the song let's go and the moms next to
us are like you know they're hype
they're moving and then tom is laughing
and he's filming them and he's recording
me and he's filming the image recording
and i'm like uncomfortable i'm just
laughing like they have
no idea this is literally me
i have no [ __ ] clue just excuse me
are you aware of who who does this song
me you're looking at him right here that
was the whole goal of making the song
we're like this one's for the milfs i
knew it wasn't anyone [ __ ] with me
for sure at the end of the song because
it was just a playlist so the song just
like finished and faded out and then
another one came on it was like the
weekend
[ __ ] i would have been so stoked i want
that to happen one time it was weird
that's like a pipe dream for me being
out in the wild and entering your own
music and seeing people organically sort
of like be like oh this is a good this
is a good one yeah yeah no we were
killing it in indianapolis man
better than oklahoma city it was funny
to just like come off of that and then
the waiter to just slam three tacos on
the table so the waiters in that place
hate you okay for
just being alive right that's generally
no bartenders for the most part hate you
it depends if they work in a place where
they get like dope tips i feel like
they're they tend to be no you don't
think no every bartender
hates you i don't think you can
generalize every bartender i'm sure
there's a select few that are nice i
have never met any of them because
you're in l.a it's because i like yeah
that's what it is they can they can
smell they look at me they're like the
smaller budding actor [ __ ] yeah clout
chaser probably yeah probably brags
about being at parties
oh yeah this is gay guy number three
from game of thrones yeah exactly this
[ __ ] guy what do you want dude yeah i
know who you are man oh gay guy number
three yeah you [ __ ] think you're a
big shot in here yeah what do you want
what will it be apherol split of course
after all spritz porsche brawl split
yeah no that's that's what you do that's
ice cream that's what you do
i do the apparel split yeah yeah
bartenders are [ __ ] generally i'm
not saying that's bad i'm saying like
they kind of deserve to be they just
have been through [ __ ]
yeah it's just drunk people all the time
the one time like in
december i was like staying sober for a
while and i uh went to a bar and i was
just like i was just perplexed by how
annoying everyone was it's crazy you
know i mean it's like midnight on a
saturday right it's like peak drunk
hours yeah people just smell like [ __ ]
yeah everyone's just like
kind of like puffy and and they're all
just being annoying you know and i'm
just sitting there like god damn how can
you how do you do this well that that i
can relate to i mean so then to serve
those people yeah
you know
the the people at kilroy's um
uh this does no shade to them the
employees of that restaurant are broken
people i've not seen spirits so low on
humans
in a long time right there's a dude
busting a table i come up to him like
hey man is it busting no kidding uh
could you imagine you actually oh my god
no no i come up to him like hey man is
it uh like self seating he's just wiping
the table and just into his own armpit
like not even over his shoulder to me he
goes yup
[Music]
i'm like for sure man rough night gotcha
i don't [ __ ] care anymore sure see
yourself or i can i don't care yeah none
of this matters what are we what are we
what is the point what is the point yeah
why did i get out of bed today funniest
[ __ ] was the a lot of the way staff was
women and i'm sure they deal with
[ __ ] all night so my [ __ ] open
reside
he goes up to one of them he's like oh
excuse me he's just like a nice guy the
woman just turns and walks away he's
like no for sure yeah definitely okay
then another waitress walks by and he
goes like do you know just
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh he's like uh do you notice women just
don't respect me
and then we sat down none of them bust
our table and then zad's like oh i'll
i'll clean the table and he gets up and
he goes to like the wait staff little
booth like where they ring people out
and like assign tables he just grabs a
rag and a bottle like a squirt bottle
and he just
wipes the table down and puts his [ __ ]
back i was crying i'm like dude it's so
cool you clocked in today he's like yeah
no yeah definitely because we're not
going to get serviced i actually did
that yeah you did it like to be a dick
or no like he just like your table
needed to get boss yeah he just knew he
just knew if the if the wait staff kept
looking at him they would just not
as long as he was at the table they
weren't gonna wipe the table down
i feel like if they would have seen him
do that though they would have gotten
majorly insulted no no i don't think
they would have they just don't even
care at all [ __ ] right then the waitress
that night because we went there because
you know you gotta go there two nights
in a row yeah yeah they treat you like
[ __ ] one night it's like gotta go back
famous kilroy's you go back the second
night and that's when you know that
whole thing happened uh we we sit down
and he busted the table whatever the
waitress brings me a menu
and i turn it over i was like oh uh is
the kitchen still doing tacos she just
grabs it flips it back over and she's
like you're on the late night menu
i was like that's a weird way of saying
it and then she goes mm-hmm
i was like whoa
all right i'll get a pepperoni pizza she
goes okay
and then just walks away like it was
it wasn't only pepperonis on that pizza
yeah it was definitely [ __ ] i hate to
tell you yeah [ __ ] pee he was a lot of
human fluids
if you look one table over the people
they deal with
there was like a table of
i don't know what the [ __ ] they were i
don't even know how to describe their
meat heads for sure okay no but i don't
know where you're gonna go with that
i don't know what the [ __ ] race they
were no no they were
i mean these dudes were just like you
know uh
mutant steroid people yeah way too
excited about innocuous stuff their
whole conversation was just slamming the
table couldn't go maybe a couple minutes
without [ __ ] boom yes bro yes i
couldn't imagine having to go up to that
every
10 minutes feeling you guys want
something else yeah
so yeah i get it i get why their spirits
were so broken